the secret type stuff but I remember I
really willed that to happen I wanted
out so bad and I'd never like kind of
mindful II wanted something to end so
bad and then uh I got laid off and I was
so so happy but you know of course i
made it as if kind of like you're really
burning me here people like you really
didn't mean while i was like i cannot
wait to this over so i can just kind of
turn engage everything and turn
everything on and then just go because i
was ready to go like I would I knew when
I wanted to be ready when that when that
job was over I can hit the ground
running and just attack attack attack
and just create as much as possible and
cuz even at that time I was like I was
secretly I have a doctor's appointment
audition you know or like I had like you
know take a comedian I'm like oh my car
was going crazy but I you know I got
laid off and it was like the best thing
that ever happened to me so I really
will have to happen I was great it was
so so great what were you doing I was uh
I worked in the legal department for the
e channel and um yeah just I just did
not just didn't like it you know wasn't
bad it was fine it wasn't bad i really
have you know i said to dig ditches so
I'm like well it wasn't digging ditches
but I was so glad when it was when it
was over just like wasn't uh you know it
just wasn't in my my heart wasn't into
my day job crazy right so looking back
on it are you working harder for
yourself now than you were when you were
punching in or maybe you were close yeah
my like kind of investment and kind of
kind of care into like what I do you
know when you go to a job and you punch
in um you know you're doing the absolute
minimum not to get fired for the mo
there's people out there that you know
we don't work hard for me um there is no
punching in and out I'm always in
especially with the internet stuff I
mean I wake up and I immediately start
working and it's never like nah i'm just
taking breaks like you know going to
sleep is a break going to the movies is
I'm just like I'm taking my like lunch
break you know and with with you know
but I phones and all that kind of stuff
like you're always you're always
connected and occasionally I force
fortunately take myself a break but I'm
now doing the absolute most i can do to
maximize everything that happens to
hopefully have the most amount of
success as
ssible and success being taking what i
think is is great what i think is funny
and interesting and having the biggest
audience possible do you ever feel a
guilt when you're not at the computer
doing something for the videos and
there's like this nagging like I should
be getting back to that sure I mean I
you know there's some you know I got to
a point where like I'm very good like it
returning messages like I'm very like on
top of things so I don't forget and I
was in pulling rows like if something
came in I worked on it and then I was
just like oh man I have some things I
have to do and then I start kind of
prioritizing which I should do um yeah I
absolutely like I'll sit there I'd be
like man I really got to send that thing
over a punch-up that script or whatever
and it kind of like let me just sit down
let me sit down and do it but I like
being at that point where i have um I've
so much awesome stuff to do you know
when I'm like when i click gotta go away
or something like that or if I don't
have enough to do I get kind of like
what can I create like what is this I'll
take it and I'll make something out of
it so yeah there's that kind of like
instinct to always kind of be moving
forward but you know I'm trying to
realize that it's okay to stop and smell
the roses or whatever people say
you